[Musique]
bonjour je cherche et le micro il est la
micro donc c'est beaucoup plus simple
comme ça
alors effectivement nous allons changer
d'échelle
alors pour le meilleur ou pour le pire
ce sera à vous de juger
en tout cas moi je voudrais vous emmener
sur ces territoires dont on entend
souvent parler
l'article les glaces etc dont on sait
aujourd'hui que ces menaces et il ya ce
fameux réchauffement climatique donc
vous avez tous entendu parler et la
fonte des banquises en particulier et
des banquises polaires
alors comment empêcher cela au demeurant
on n'y est pas arrivé
aujourd'hui on a vu les coop 21 22 23 ça
a commencé la première en 1995 je crois
et il n'ya pas toujours pas de résultats
tangibles
la terre continue de se réchauffer et
les glaces de fondre alors qu'elle roule
j'ai cherché à jouer dans cette affaire
moi quand j'étais gamin ou adolescents
il y avait un truc qui me qu'il
travaillait qui me taraudait c'est à
dire que le monde qui m'entoure est la
société dite de consommation de
production etc y compris l'enseignement
le lycée ce qu'ont essayé nous apprendre
tout ça
j'avais l'intuition profonde que c'était
une vaste supercherie
et puis j'étais aussi un bon un jeune un
jeune garçon comme beaucoup et je me
disais mais plus tard et falloir que je
sois un homme à un moment ou un autre
à quel moment je serai que je suis un
homme et à quoi elle s'est en définitive
j'ai pas été préparé à ça non plus je
savais pas grand chose mais à 18 ans de
la vie je n'ai pas voyager j'avais voilà
j'avais une grande curiosité évidemment
pour tous pour le monde pour la
connaissance pour un autre chose et mais
qui n'étaient pas satisfaites donc j'ai
décidé de prendre le taureau par les
cornes et de pas trop écouter ce qu'ont
raconté où les recommandations qu'on
pouvait me
ma portée et de fixer le barème de ma
propre éducation aussi roulé de ma
propre initiation parce qu'on parle bien
de cela il ya un passage normalement
faut ça serait encore dans l'afrique je
sais pas où on va
face à ces lions à la sagaie au moyen
âge était chevalier qui partait en tout
cas l'initiation se mettre à l'épreuve à
l'épreuve du réel soit nu c'est à dire
sans sens sans protection en effet de
dépouiller face à la réalité du monde au
devant du cas l'on se dirige voilà c'est
l'aventuré en fait c'est la vertu de
laventure que de se construire et
d'apprendre qu'ils menaient alors pour
partir dans cette démarche là je suis
dit qu'est ce que tu crains le plus ce
que je redoutais le plus physiquement
j'entends c'était l'eau dix ans un
piètre nageurs et le froid est jamais
allé aux sports d'hiver etc
j'ai un petit syndrome de raynaud donc
on va s'occuper de ça et deux ans plus
tard j'étais guide d'expédition dans les
régions polaires en kayak de mer
donc c'était c'était le pire de l'aide
la formule qu'on peut imaginer j'ai fait
ça pendant 20 ans voilà et je pense que
si j'ai réussi c'est que j'avais une
telle volonté de vivre de découvrir et
surtout d'éprouver les choses par
moi-même plutôt que de devoir les
apprendre par coeur sans le les
ressentir
c'est ce qui fait qu'on ne retient pas
bien évidemment bien que j'avais
tellement besoin d'un repère qui soit un
repère je dirais un peu supérieure peut
être ce qu avait une dimension
métaphysique l'arctique savez c'est
comme une homme c'est comme un temple
longtemps j'ai pas cru au réchauffement
climatique je me suis dit bon c'est pas
très grave
effectivement les glaciers reculent un
peu mais ça va revenir c'est ainsi que
le passager et j'imaginais surtout que
l'arctique ne se laisseraient jamais
prendre par l'humanité par 7,7 cette
civilisation à industriels dont je me
méfiais temps et j'ai été blessé à
partir du moment où j'ai admis que tout
cela allait finir les glaces
effectivement disparaissait et j'ai fini
par l'admettre
peut-être en même temps que vous tous
c'est à dire vers les années 2000 en
particulier
2005 jusqu'en 2007 au moment de la
sortie du film d'al gore une vérité qui
dérange
là haut on est bien certain nombre de
chiffres qui sortait j'ai approfondi de
la question et en 2010 en 2007 il y
avait les élections présidentielles avec
le pacte écologique de nicolas hulot
l'abbé sarkozy mais qui tous deux
s'étaient sentis obligés d'intégrer la
question de la survie de l'humanité dans
leur programme électoral crois que
c'était la première fois de l'histoire
de la république ou de la cinquième ou
toutes les autres qu'on se préoccuper
d'un enjeu écologique globale s'ils ont
reçu un enjeu national ça disparu depuis
peut-être le problème était résolu sujet
toujours est il qu'il y avait une sorte
de mobilisation y compris de la presse
la presse de la mise et paris match et
bien d'autres magazine titrait la voilà
à l'on me survivra changement climatique
etc
il y avait le feu le soleil vert vous
savez qu'ils étaient offertes avec pst
je crois c'est vrai donc ce qu'elle
filme catastrophique pour nous alerter
de ce qui est en train de se passer
et moi j'ai voulu participer à cette
aventure comment parce que je
m'apercevais que je fréquentais des
périodes des régions très rare je les
fréquente et comme ceux ci ont donc en
kayak de mer et que j'étais un malgré
moi le témoin d'un milieu qui est en
train de disparaître c'est à dire que
cette image que vous voyez là peut-être
ces offres impossible de la prendre en
photo dc 15 20 ou 30 ans ça c'est
résidence 30 ans assurément il
n'existera plus c'est à dire ça ça sert
un document d'archivés d'histoire
naturelle est ce que vous voyez c'est à
dire ce que vous voyez c'est de la
banquise pluriannuelle la banquise
polaire les différents centres et de la
banquise annuel est normal et à la
banquise polaire c'est que l'annuel se
forment l'hiver un choriste roméas gelés
et puis elles font au printemps mois de
juin juillet il ya plus de glace et
après on se met à naviguer correspond
peut naviguer partout dans l'arctique
pratiquement sauf là où la banquise ne
font pas parce qu'elle est trop épaisse
elle s'est accumulée pendant plusieurs
années et elle s'est formée sur l'océan
glacial arctique
on voit très bien sur cette image c'est
voilà donc le l'océan glacial arctique
est recouvert
la paire n permanente et il a un rôle
sur le climat déterminant vous imaginez
bien parce que l'eau sous l'eau sur les
ailes et à -1 degrés 8
c'est à dire la limite de congélation de
l'eau de mer elle va rencontrer les eaux
du gulf stream qui sont à plus 5 degrés
quand on honore et puis la différence de
température va va avoir un effet
dynamique sur les cours les eaux froides
vont couler et vont descendre jusqu'en
antarctique elles vont oxygéner le fond
des océans parce que c'est plus l'eau
est froide plus elle capte l'oxygène
comme tous les autres gaz par ailleurs
le co2 pareil et ce qui fait que le le
froid est le système chaud froid sur
planète c'est essentiel au dynamisme
déjà des océans et de la planète
globalement et il y à deux endroits sur
terre on peut observer la banquise
pluriannuelle on le peut l'observer sur
la côte orientale du groenland la région
damas à licques
thaci la schola lui sont en fait toutes
les côtes est -ce qui fait face à
l'islande et on peut l'observer sur les
3,2 de smith du 3d smith et le nord
ouest du groenland l'extrême nord ouest
du groenland et ne reste du canada on va
en reparler beaucoup dans les minutes
qui viennent alors la première fois je
suis allé sur la banquise pluriannuelle
c'était pour organiser cette fameuse
expédition de dérive sur les glaces avec
avec pour ambition de évidemment de
sensibiliser comme on dit c'est à
l'époque 1,7 et 2008 2009 de
sensibiliser le public à la disparition
des glaces alors est il est assistant
civilisé depuis je n'en sais rien
toujours est il que dans les faits s'est
pas passé grand chose on peut le
constater et que la glace continuent
toujours de fondre au risque évidemment
que les courants océaniques
disparaissent et au risque de précipiter
une fonte de la calotte glaciaire du
groenland qui a trois kilomètres
d'épaisseur en son centre
et il suffirait que le groenland perdre
un quart des 100 volume de glace sachant
qu'il se passera la même chose sur le
continent antarctique en proportion eh
bien les océans monteraient de 3 m et si
on est tout à fait envisageable d'ici
l'échéance d'un siècle c'est-à-dire
trois mètres de vers en plus n'existe
plus alexandrie
à bangkok new york un certain nombre
d'autres villes relativement importante
ce qui fait qu'on va vers une échéance
ou si ça continue et ça continue ou on a
à peu près certain que le monde dans
lequel on vit
fondée sur la mondialisation des
échanges d'une certaine aisance liées au
transport maritime aérien tout ça est
bien ne pourra plus exister il va
s'effondrer
par la force des choses et est-ce un
phénomène physique doullens boisse des
scientifiques qui on parle aux
politiques et qui réagissent de
distendre bien obligé de réagir les
politiques en organisant ses grandes
concurrentes conférences qui ont pour
vertu d'informer le public de ce qui se
passe mais est ce qu'on a vraiment envie
de savoir ce qui se passe parce que
c'est quand même pas très encourageant
d'autant plus qu'on n'a pas de réponse à
la question comment faire finalement
pour réduire nos émissions de co2 qui
sont ans qui sont en cause pour la
parenthèse sam et rapide le co2 c'est
quand même du carbone qui est stocké
dans les strates géologiques depuis 200
à 300 millions d'années et il avait été
très bien là où il est il n'avait pas à
se retrouver brusquement projeté à la
fois dissous dans les océans et dissout
dans l'atmosphère donc on a voulu
modifier la composition chimique à la
fois de l'atmosphère est à la fois des
essais ce qui est phénoménal dans
l'histoire de la planète et simplement
parce qu'on a rejeté le carbone et on
sait que la vie sur terre c'est quand
même le cycle du carbone un sinon on
sera pas là donc on a créé un
déséquilibre artificiellement et ce
pétrole et ce gaz charbon si rien
d'autre que la fossilisation de
l'énergie du soleil qui a brillé il y à
200 à 300 millions d'années c'est
l'énergie du soleil qui a été conservé
par des végétaux animaux sont sous
utilisées donc ils ont le pétrole
aujourd'hui et qu on restitue
aujourd'hui c'est à dire quand on vit au
dessus de nos moyens c'est à dire on dit
par seulement avec le soleil du jour
mais avec le soleil qu'il ya très
longtemps et qui en réserve évidemment
limite donc enfin ça ça et bien la
solution selon moi c'était sensibiliser
mais on voyait que ça ça marchait pas
pour moi je me laisser dériver en kayak
de mer donc sur ce morceau de glace qui
sont à portée vers le sud pour témoigner
de la fonte de cet élément et sa
disparition c'est l aventure des
robinsons des glaces
alors que pour être concret
je sais pas si c'est pas du tout c'est
passé du tout sinon on va prendre ça de
façon de façon légère j'ai un
thermomètre dans cette dans cette
bibliothèque
c'est en moi il fait 29 5 degrés je sais
bien que les spots sont nombreux mais
c'est à dire qu'on est à 10 degrés de
plus que ce qui est autorisé légalement
se chauffer chez soi à plus de 19 degrés
d'une infraction paraît-il de 5e
catégorie kz a peut être changé
peut-être troisième catégorie 5e
catégorie ses 1500 euros d'amendé
pourquoi suite au premier choc pétrolier
la 174 75
on a créé cette loi pour limiter la
consommation d'énergie fossile
précisément est ce qui a permis de
limiter un petit peu sauf qu'à cette
époque on avait un pouvoir un
gouvernement qu'ils étaient capables au
nom de l'intérêt commun les exercer une
pression sur le confort personnel
le confort individuel aujourd'hui c'est
devenu impensable c'est à dire l'intérêt
commun y compris de conserver un climat
diable pour tout le monde ne justifie
pas on exerce une pression sur le
confort des individus qui doit
finalement qui ont finalement le droit
de ceux de sauter autant qu'ils veulent
c'était juste pour l'anecdote mais c'est
vraiment réel c'est une loi qui est qui
appliqua le la climatisation c'est
exactement pareil
ces 26 degrés la limite au-delà c'est en
cl légal s'il fait pas 26 degrés quand
un pli matisse alors voyons que mes
petit périple ne fonctionné pas tant que
ça j'ai une idée
alors cette idée ce qu'elle est bonne
c'est à vous d'en juger
je travaille dessus depuis cinq ans elle
nous ramène dans le détroit de smith
c'est à dire la côte est du groenland
sont les glaces pluriannuelles les plus
faciles d'accès plus difficile à
rejoindre ce sont celles qui se trouvent
au niveau de tulle et les derniers
reculer vous avez peut-être lu jean
malaurie
et là bas on a un détroit où l'amérique
rejoint l'europe il ya plus que 40 km
entre les deux dans l'ain nationale par
lequel circule le courant du labrador
prend sa naissance dans un los angles
est ce l arctique et qui rafraîchit
toute la côte est des états unis
et bien par ce courant et veste auriez
des masses considérables de ce qu'on
peut considérer que les classes les plus
épaisses les dernières glace pure enel
les plus épaisses du monde
non je suis allé là bas pour les
observer parce que personne ne le
faisait et pour marquer le coup
j'ai imaginé que cet îlot qui s'appelle
les lens c'est un kilomètre carré et on
voit mieux sur la carte il se trouve à
mille kilomètres distance du pôle nord
géographique trouve juste à bon à droite
c'est le canada 20 go canada et à droite
le danemark donc l'europe croît avec le
groenland et sept îles se trouvait
exactement sur la ligne de partage des
eaux entre les deux pays ce qui fait que
les deux pays n'ont toujours pas se
déterminer à qui elle appartenait donc a
priori il appartient à personne donc
s'il appartient appartiennent pourquoi
ne nous appartiendra t'elle pas à nous
sachant que si nous nous approprions
cette île ne le ferions pas pour dire
voilà on a un territoire en plus on peut
jouir la situation et profiter du chenal
parce que quand le pouvoir a fondu on
enverra no cars go par là non on le
laisse se l'approprient au nom de
l'intérêt commun pour dire arrêtez stop
réfléchissons et travaillons plutôt que
travaille à l industrie et le commerce
qui fait tourner le monde
malheureusement travaillons plutôt la
conscience et le sens des
responsabilités ça ça fait un peu moins
tourner le monde
malheureusement c'est essentiel est ce
qu'on pourrait dire de phénomènes qu'on
vit actuellement c'est qu'on place ce
qui est essentiel en périphérie l'art
lettres l'homme l'humain le sens de la
vie la spiritualité pourquoi cibler là
où vais-je ou hulu a disparu de ma mère
quand il décide et voilà c'était
essentiel est tous assez marginal ont le
culte mais on met au centre
en définitive tout ce qui est utile à la
quantité et le spectaculaire le matériel
et puis évidemment le le bilan comptable
donc je trouve que tout ça c'est sûr sur
le dos d'une planète consomme 1 qu'on
mange de plus en plus les deux plantes
plus en plus rapidement on est sa base
de la consommation de tout et de
n'importe quoi jusqu'à jusqu'à tout
évidemment qui n'est plus rien donc
c'est ils pouvaient nous rappeler à la
conscience à notre devoir l'être humain
se dire qu'on est que passager on ne
peut pas penser l'avenir si on ne naît
pas imprégnés il
pas habiter déjà par le passé par
l'histoire on est dans un mouvement le
présent n'est que la conséquence de tout
ce qui nous précèdent n'y a pas de
présent il n'y aurait même pas de
langage pour communiquer ce n'est pas de
passer si des gens il ya il ya 1000 ou
2000 ans n'avait pas inventé les mots
qu'on utilise aujourd'hui donc le
présent c'est bien mais sans passé nous
mène nulle part
donc laissez travail de conscience et ce
travail l'accès du travail aussi de
philosophie et quel travail de
responsabilité collective que pouvait
représenter est incarnée selon moi que
ma proposition sept îles et c'est pour
ça que j'ai tenté alors j'ai créé
allez-vous s'appelle romain sont des
glaces qui vient de sortir chez pocket
d'ailleurs il ya quelques semaines qui
relate son dernier périple pour tenter
de l'atteindre il en ce que général
jamais vraiment réussi à atteindre
physiquement mais c'est pourtant je me
suis donné du mal et là on n'était pas
très loin est sûre il n'est pas non pas
sur une île terrestre mais sur un but
d'un magnifique spécimen de banquise
plus rien eu et justement qui fait une
quinzaine de 7 15 20 mètres d'épaisseur
et c'est devenu aujourd'hui rarissime
on avait emporté tous les chevaux sont
le voyez tous les drapeaux du monde
c'est naïf 1 c'est très naïf et
effectivement cette photo qui n'a pas
fait le tour du monde jusqu'en bien même
leurs étals fait elle aurait pas non
plus changé grand chose parce qu'on
n'arrête pas le le mouvement du monde et
les les coop
on voit bien que tous les chefs d'état
du monde n'arrive pas à infléchir la
réalité parce que le n'appartient pas à
la gouvernance en définitive de réparer
le climat ou même l'écologie et et moi
j'en suis là à à plaider cette cause là
jusqu'au moment où j'ai créé ce site on
se souvient c'est pas vous connaissez
peut-être d'ailleurs j'avais fait une
certaine publication de publicité autour
de ce site là depuis un certain temps où
il était question vraiment de se
ressaisir et voir d'imaginer un
dispositif technique matériel qui
permettrait physiquement de retenir la
circulation des glaces dans le détroit
de smith grâce à cette île parce que je
n'allais très très étroit donc en
maintenant les glaces en amont on
pourrait peut-être retarder la
disparition définitive c'est banquise là
et donc retarder la montée des océans
cette idée qui intéresse beaucoup de
gens n'a pour le moment ni aucun soutien
concret l'ormeau des soutiens moraux
c'est parce qu'ils manquent mais il ya
quand même une difficulté aujourd'hui à
s'impliquer simplement s'impliquent et
je parle même pas de s'engager
l'engagement celui pour lequel les vins
finalement où vous sa vie au risque
parfois de la mettre en danger et bien
c'est quelque chose qui est devenu assez
rare alors comment se sortir d'une
situation inextricable ou simplement
difficile si on s'engage pas pleinement
et c'est un peu la morale de cette
histoire parce que au bout du compte
j'ai l'impression d'être presque tout
seul à porter ce message avec vous
aujourd'hui
mais il y adhérer ne suffit pas à à
modifier les choses les choses et
surtout un jeu avoir une influence
constructif sur le cours des choses qui
semble-t-il beaucoup plus puissants que
nous même et si je devais résumer cette
discussion
1 ce constat je m'inspirerai de 7 cette
phrase que j'aime beaucoup de vaclav
havel sans révolution globale va se
faire de la conscience humaine
rien ne peut changer positivement même
dans la sphère de l'existence humaine et
la marche du monde vers la catastrophe
sociale écologique et culturel était
réversible ça je pense que c'est
fondamental il ya d'autres penseurs qui
le disent de façon aussi juste votre
lame avait les terres la fois un
politicien est un philosophe c'est ça
existait encore je prends je suis pas si
on a beaucoup aujourd'hui encore lent
tout cas les mots qui mom qui me touche
c'est la révolution globale de la sphère
de la conscience
même est en fait l'île hand c'est ça
c'est tenter d'amorcer cette révolution
globale de la sphère de la conscience
humaine alors c'est une ambition
démesurée je vous la corde mais l'outil
est là et l outil il a besoin de bras il
a besoin lui aussi de son essence de son
pétrole pour avancer pour aller plus
loin aujourd'hui il est un petit peu un
petit peu en panne en attente de jours
meilleurs et et c'est le destin de
chacun de nous qui se joue derrière
cette histoire en définitive et j'avais
cette obsession je vous parlais au début
de 2,2 de sauver sauver le monde la
forêt amazonienne après les glaces après
elle sauve et moi même aussi peut-être
le salut de l'âme c'est peut-être
important
qui sait
[Applaudissements]